c'est pourquoi la regarde pas ce que dit
sûr que t'as pas de zz que personne et
on délire
j'ai cru vraiment que tu faisais partie
de l'immeuble d'en face j'ai vraiment eu
un doute un moment parce que bon bah
tout ça je vais te dire aujourd'hui on
est dans un monde on peut déménager très
vite comme moi je bosse et que je vais
l'apprendre l'après midi et tout ça tout
ça on a quand même retrouvé la preuve
que ton délire et bien en chair en os
sur ce plateau
voilà et je parle pas de moi regarde
souvient total 6,6 encore des images de
moi isabelle dans les loges tout plein
délire je veux un jour devenir garde
j'agis je préfère vous le dire tout de
suite dit avec vous êtes ma femme
préférée au monde
en amitié en amitié bien entendu puisque
je ne franchirai jamais le pas à part si
vous me le demandez
[Rires]
mais c'est sûr mais je vous le dis on a
tous quelqu'un pour qui on laisserait
tout tomber et virginie je laisse tout
tomber pour elle j'ai un texto de
ballast connard ces points
[Applaudissements]
les et vous voulez que je réagisse bah
oui je rassure vous m'avez dit la même
chose
le but faire agir en virginie c'est
simple en votre présence et en la
présence d'axelle laffont jean sarkozy
c'est pas bon c'est d'ailleurs si
quelqu'un a quelque chose à dire qu'il
le dise matin dans les images que nous
venons de voir oui vous avez
explicitement oui dit à virginie ledoyen
mais oui qu'est ce que c'était mais
sinon la femme de votre ruse et qu'un
pas laisser tomber pour peu qu est-ce
toujours le cas des jeunes et la
question bien je vais traduire pour les
anglophones qui nous regardent et cette
trouvaille géniale audois gagnent
bataille can't let it be me semble clair
exactement donc quel est votre question
est ce que vous êtes toujours prêt à
tout laisser tomber pour vivre leur vie
le doyen tueur vous dire la vérité et je
vais le dire les français ont besoin de
savoir et je vais leur dire il est bon
alors virginie ledoyen tout ça non
virginie elle sait que franchement où c
est là l atout pour elle vraiment oui et
1 n'est rien ou pas non il n'ya pas deux
mais on est étonné c'est une excuse at
on pas non plus c'est une main mais oui
c'est une amie c'est devenue une amie
avec le temps qui a fait les choses
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
énormément
malheureusement ça n'est pas mon délire
allait plus bas de 6 a toujours été mon
délire virgine ledoyen c'est le délire
de tout le monde mais moi ça n'est pas
mon délire parce que on est dans
l'amitié n'a pas elle et moi on pourrait
me thomas daum et ami tommy ton alors
axelle laffont il est là pour la bla
bobby galeuses domination barre était de
7 avions par mois quand on est à nice et
lille avait été franchement se dit la
vérité là vous n'avez pas envie de
sortir avec un prof de psp
[Applaudissements]
l'été
regardez ce qu'elle vient de dire oui ni
non c'est non c'est non amis comme ça
c'est tout fait gémir tout nu tous les
deux dans un lycéen dit superposés du
oui c'est vrai on est on s'adore mais
vraiment je la dois à weedon amis et je
serai comme si je sortais que valérie
bénaïm mais non mais non c'est pas
pareil machine après tout pourquoi parce
qu apparemment bien un album pêchu
une information que je n'avais pas
d'armé a virgin est en tout cas
franchement je vous aime énormément
voilà vous êtes à la mort tout comme
axel que j'aime énormément